cause I don't need somebody to scold me
don't need somebody that hurts me don't
need somebody who feels weak standing
next to me
Kelly Clarkson drops two new singles and
it's not hard to figure out
this is Breakup music divorce is a
really
thing too much I've had to live for put
my life on hold for
I'm always pleasing someone honestly now
I'm done
Kelly split from her husband Brandon
Blackstock after seven years of marriage
in 2020. I didn't even know I'd ever get
married it took another two years to
finalize their divorce and another year
after that for Kelly to finally drop the
songs there's a lot of questions that I
just have to answer before releasing it
for myself those questions apparently
answered and the tracks seemed to send a
clear message even from the titles alone
Kelly's focused on me and mine I've
fought my entire career just to be me I
am an open book and labels and people
frown upon it early on
um but I I don't do it for anyone else
honestly on the song me Kelly hints at
trouble in a relationship but without
naming names
[Music]
thank you
gave you reasons
I feel like if you're hiding something
there must be something wrong with it
like and and there's nothing wrong with
anything life just kind of happens and
it takes turns that you don't expect
yeah Kelly's keeping things cryptic
likely to protect her and Brandon's kids
the interesting thing is it's not just
about she and I think that's why I
wanted to address it is there's a lot of
Hearts involved here I care 100 more
about my children than I do anything
else on this planet they share
eight-year-old daughter River and
seven-year-old son Remington that's been
the the hard thing of like yes I'm
willing to share my experience and yes
it is the worst but at the same time I
have to think Hmm like what I say is a
domino effect in other people's lives I
can't believe I let you in I can't
believe I stay as long as I stay
in mine she reflects on the pain she
felt in the wake of a split I hope one
day someone will take your hard and hold
it tight make you feel like you're
Invincible deep inside and right when
you think that it's perfect they cross
the line and steal your shine like you
did mine yeah she's not holding back
[Music]
[Applause]
the singles are just a taste of what's
to come from Kelly's 10th studio album
chemistry out June 23rd is really great
and it's very honest I don't know how
anybody I'll just be real with you goes
through
grief like divorce any kind of grief any
kind of loss without having an outlet
like it has I have written like 60 songs
like it's like an insane amount of
getting it out
um you know and I think that that's a
blessing in itself anytime you go
through some it's like it's a such an
awesome thing to have that as an outlet
regardless of people hear it or not
um not everybody has that
[Music]
thank you